♪ ♪ ♪
- Ambiance apaisante :
nous sommes dans les bureaux
de l'agence de marketing
Clark Influence.
♪ ♪ ♪
On crée ici des publicités
en partenariat avec
des influenceurs web.
L'équipe est jeune, branchée.
- Trier, archiver...
- Mais c'est sur l'utilisation
du bonuxuxux courrier
électronique que doit tabler
la directrice du développement
depuis que les serveurs ont
atteint leur pe e e capacité.
ANNE-JULIE KARCHER, directrice
développement, Clark Influence
- On voit que Google nous donne
régulièrement des alertes
en dis: : : "Hé, les 'drives'
sont pleins, les boîtes 'mail'
sont pleines."
- Comment ça va, Anne-Julie?
- Bien, ça va.
- Un signal clair que
les courriels étaient devenus
trop volumineux, ce qui a
poussé Anne-Julie à donner
des formations pour éviter
que les courriels nuisent
à la productivité.
- Moi, quand je suis conrérérée
sur quelque chose, je sais
que si j'ai un pop-up
qui va arriver, bien, tu te
déconcentres, puis te remettre
dedans, ça te prend 10 minutes.
Donc, au final, bien, tu n'es
plus du tout effe... efficace
comme tu pourrais l'être.
- Selo c c chercheur,
les travailleurs reçoivent en
moyenne 70 courriels par jour,
et en envoient une quarantaine.
PLACIDE POBA-NZAOU, professeur,
École sciences gestion, UQAM
- La plupart des études arrivent
à la conclusion que quand c'est
pas bien géré, c'est un frein
à la productivité.
- Plus du quart de l'emploi
du temps serait alloué
au traitement des courriels,
une perte de performance
qui a un prix.
- Les perturbations numériques,
de façon générale, sont estimées
à environ, en moyenne, entre
5000 et 10 000 par employé
par année.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Amine travaille à partir
d'un café. De retour d'une fin
de semaine, il compte
180 messages non lus.
AMINE SABRI, directeur
de comptes, Insight Canada
- C'est sûr que des fois, une
fois qu'on accumule énormément
de courriels, ça peut paraître
insurmone.e.e.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour y arriver, il réserve
de trois à quatre blocs de
quatre heures dans sa semaine,
consacrés exclusivement
à la gestion de sa boîte
de réception.
- En fermant tout, puis
en "focusant" sur tes courriels,
bien, ça te permet de te mettre
dans un genre de bulle,
puis de dire : OK, c'est ça
le travail que je vais faire
et... Et le plus dur, c'est
de commencer, puis là, il y a
un autre courriel qui arrive.
Là, tu... tu sautes
sur le prochain.
- Le talon d'Achille
du courriel, c'est quand
il devient omniprésent.
SONIA LUPIEN, directrice, Centre
d'études sur le st h h humain
- Notre attention se fragmente
entre deux tâches : une tâche,
on revient; une tâche,
on revient. n n n étudiant
le courriel, on s'est rendu
compte que c'était une machine
à attention fragmentée.
- Le cerveau humain a se
limites. Une fois perturbé,
il faut en moyenne 23 minutes
pour regagner sa pleine
concentration.
- Et la cause prre
de la surcharge mentale,
les gens pensent que c'est
l'amoncellement de travail
qu'ils ont, c'est l'attention
fragmentpapaparce que ça demande
une attention au cerveau
qu'il est incapable de générer.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le secret d'Anne-Julie :
ieieier son courrier électroniqe
avant de quitter le bureau.
- Je fais tac, tac, tac et tac!
Ça devient de l'éducation.
Si on te dit jamais de trier tes
c'est pas... Enfin, personne...
si personne te le dit,
tu le sais pas qu'il faut
le faire.
- Mieux vaut dompter
le courriel, parce qu'il est
après tout incontournable.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughe